sûr aussi
bas complètement mais le gouvernement
avec lui puisque c'est un choix de
laisser sur qui les dirigent dans
l'école on a alerté au mois de décembre
le conseil scientifique nous mêmes à la
mission kobe du sénat on avait appelé
l'attention sur la nécessité d'avoir un
protocole plus adapté il aurait été
possible d'ailleurs de décaler la
rentrée scolaire de quelques jours ou
d'une semaine pour prendre le temps de
mettre en place un protocole le
gouvernement ne l'a pas voulu il a
choisi clairement de laisser circuler le
virus le résultat c'est un chaos total
dans les écoles alors en ce moment on
est dans le débat au sénat sur le projet
de loi instaurant le pass vaccinale les
échanges vont reprendre à partir de
16h30 après les questions d'actualité et
hier soir il y a eu un débat sur la
vaccination obligatoire que vous
défendez les sénateurs socialistes alors
ça n'a pas été adopté par une majorité
de sénateurs mais c'était quand même
important pour vous de réaffirmer à ce
principe d'abord je pense qu'on sent
bien dans l'hémicycle et y compris chez
les propos du ministre qui a de
l'inconfort sur cette question parce que
au fond c'est une une question de
cohérence il faut d'abord dire
clairement le principe sur lequel on
légifère et nous nous disons le principe
c'est que tout le monde doit être
vacciné et donc c'est l'obligation
vaccinale universelle qui rassemble les
français pas qui les divisent entre et à
partir de là on discute des outils des
outils pour convaincre les français
qu'ils sont pas vaccinés des outils pour
contraindre car il faut les deux et le
pass vaccinale fait partie de ces outils
est donc nous on est prêts à discuter
dans ce cadre là et c'est ce qu'on fait
on voit bien que le ministre était gêné
puisqu'il a dit ça n'est pas un nom
mordicus ça a été son expression venant
après c'est une obligation déguisé donc
on voit bien l'ambiguïté du mil et puis
la majorité sénatoriale est étonnamment
silencieuse la rapporteur a dit qu' elle
regrettait cette obligation vaccinale
dissimulé ça a été ces termes et donc
nous nous avions comme depuis le début
une position cohérente et moi je prends
le pari que cette pandémie ne
malheureusement pas terminée et que tôt
ou tard et j'espère le plus tôt possible
nous viendrons à ce principe qui est un
principe juste clair et transparent en
tout cas l'autre critique crête par
olivier ferrand sur la vaccination
obligatoire c'est qu'il y a
difficilement des moyens de contrôle à
mettre en place c'est à dire que hormis
le pass vaccinale qu'elle serait bernard
jomier les autres moyens de contrôle de
la vaccination obligatoire contre istres
on estime que le pavage vaccinale est un
outil de contrôle qui fonctionne il
fonctionnera sur l'obligation vaccinale
sinon c'est que le ministre estime que
c'est un outil qui ne fonctionne pas
donc il faut qu'ils aient de sa part un
peu plus au cohérence et peut-être une
pointe de mauvaise foi en moins en
l'occurrence il y a une sanction qui
doit être prévu et nous l'avions prévu
dans l'amendement et puis ait les moyens
de contrôle et donc c'est la discussion
sur le passage final qu'on peut appeler
autres membres est ce qu'il faudrait par
exemple bernard genier taxer les non
vaccinés comme c'est ce qui va être mise
en place au québec au canada alors on ne
taxe pas dans le droit français quand
vous ne respectez pas une obligation
vous avez un procès verbal d'infraction
et oui il enjoint au moins
symboliquement merci beaucoup je viens
d'avoir répondu à mes questions merci
merci beaucoup alexandre pour cette
nouvelle réaction autour et bien du
passage final et de la situation
sanitaire et puis en mer va maintenant
entendre l'homme qui travaille de plus
sur ce projet de loi instaurant le pass
vaccinale cet homme est bien c'est
philippe bas le rapporteur du texte
sénateurs l'est républicain de la manche
il est à votre micro alexandre peur
c'est rare oui avec sénateur républicain
de la manche et rapporteur de ce projet
loi instaurant le pass vaccine a alors
philippe bas une majorité de sénateurs
ont voté des modifications des
modifications qui viennent pour une
phare de la commission des lois et puis
il y en a d'autres par exemple sur les
jauge dans les stades dans les salles il
ya eu également hier soir et bien la
suppression de ce principe qui
permettait aux gérants d'établissements
recevant du public le faire des
contrôles d'identité il y aura également
dans le texte sénatorial normalement et
bien ce seuil de dix mille
hospitalisations pour pouvoir appliquer
le pass vaccinale est ce que philippe
bas vous ne croyez pas que toutes ces
modifications sénatoriales finalement
elles vont complexifier la mise en place
de ce dispositif
elles vont au contraire l'équilibré et
faire en sorte que les restrictions qui
peuvent être nécessaires pour les
libertés pour lutter au mieux contre le
coc vide soit strictement proportionnées
et c'est le rôle du sénat
vous voyez que nous avons un débat qui
était un débat ce ram c'est aussi un
débat responsable et nous voulons la
fois être efficace dans la lutte contre
le coc vide et respectueux de nos
libertés c'est pour ça que nous disons
quand les conditions sanitaires ne
l'exigeront plus et nous mettons les
critères dans la loi avec le nombre
d'hospitalisations pas par exemple mais
aussi le nombre de vaccinations mais
aussi la vitesse de circulation du virus
le pass sanitaire de vannes le pass
vaccinale maintenant devra disparaître
de lui même automatiquement sans
attendre une décision gouvernementale
législateur que nous sommes ne veut pas
faire de chèque en blanc il ne veut pas
laisser les pleins pouvoirs au
gouvernement son rôle de représentation
de la nation c'est bien de poser lui
même les limites et c'est ce que nous
faisons il ya une limite selon une
majorité de sénateurs c'est et bien j'en
parlais à l'instant le principe de ne
pas pouvoir faire de contrôle d'identité
si on n'est pas policier les gérants de
restaurants ne pourront pas faire des
contrôles d'identité sur les clients qui
vont montrer leurs passes vaccinale ça
c'est une ligne rouge à ne pas franchir
pour le sénat nous avons trouvé un
accord sur ce point qui est très
majoritaire à ses venues de tous les
groupes là c'est le souci
de préserver les libertés et c'est aussi
une appréciation sur l'inefficacité de
ce qui avait été prévu au fond on dit
vous pouvez si vous avez des bonnes
raisons de penser que il pourrait y
avoir une fronde et ses termes enfin les
personnels des restaurants des cafés ou
des cinémas ne sont pas des auxiliaires
de la police nationale ils n'ont pas les
mêmes pouvoirs ni même la même formation
pour vérifier l'identité des gens et ils
ne peuvent pas être mis vis-à-vis de
leurs clients dans une position qui
serait celle d'un contrôle d'identité
déjà le texte de l'assemblée nationale
est peut-être un texte au fond qui ne
faisait aucune obligation aux
restaurateurs et qui certainement
n'aurait pas trouvé à s'appliquer et mes
collègues retrouver plus normal de ne
pas faire de faux semblants dans ce
domaine alors on a retiré une
disposition qui n'avaient réellement pas
une grande utilité philippe bas j'ai une
question pour le sénateur les
républicains que vous êtes on a un
groupe l'est républicain au sénat qui
est en majorité favorables aux pass
vaccinale modifié mais il ya quand même
eh bien les dizaine de sénateurs qu'ils
pourraient s'abstenir pour qu'ils
pourraient voter contre ce principe du
pass vaccinale est ce qu'il serait
irresponsable la position
de notre groupe est une position qui est
quand même avec une majorité écrasante
extrêmement unie et ceux de nos
collègues qui ne partagent pas notre
avis nous les respectons ne jetons
jamais l'anathème nous débattons chacun
est dans son droit tous les sénateurs
ont été élus par leurs grands électeurs
élus route une égale légitimité pour ce
prénom se prononcer si si c'est pas un
camp disciplinaire
bien sûr merci beaucoup au chili bat
d'avoir était à mes côtés pour répondre
à mes questions je vais vous laisser
regagner l'hémicycle puisque dans
quelques secondes ce sera le début de
cette séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement et on va se diriger dans la
tribune de presse de l'hémicycle du
sénat retrouver steve jour dans six
jours dans quel va être le programme cet
après midi la séance alexandre qui va
débuter dans quelques instants
maintenant je vais débuter par un
hommage un hommage organisé en l'honneur
de david sa solide à vitaly vous savez
c'est ce président du parlement européen
décédé hier à l'âge de 65 ans il était
social démocrate et président du
parlement européen depuis 2010 9 jarrar
sheva en dire quelques mots le sénat va
donc rendre un hommage à cet amoureux de
l'europe et puis il sera aussi question
à cet après midi de la journée noire
attendu demain dans l'éducation
nationale plus de la moitié des écoles
vont être fermés pourquoi et bien parce
que les enseignants font en grain ils
sont en colère contre le protocole
sanitaire du gouvernement ils sont en
colère contre jean michel blanquer le
gouvernement va donc être interpellé
dans quelques instants à ce sujet du
côté de jean-michel bancaire justement
la parade tient en quelques mots on ne
fait pas grève contre un virus il
devrait le répéter la séance vient
d'être ouverte le monde l'europe
agissent après tout l aventure
[Musique]
il y en a t'il en séance
je n'en vois point le procès verbal est
donc adoptée sous les réserves d'usagé
monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
mes chers collègues je souhaite que nous
saluions la mémoire du président du
parlement
européen va vite ça sonic cd hier
il personnifiait par ses qualités
propres et dans l'exercice de ses
responsabilités les valeurs de l'union
européenne
c'était un homme de liberté
en tant que journaliste il connaissait
plus que tout autre le prix d'un liberté
d'expression et de la liberté de la
presse il était libre d'esprit
indépendant
peu enclin à suivre les mots d'ordre
d'où qu'ils émanent
c'était un homme intrinsèquement attaché
au parlementarisme
il n'aura eu de cesse pendant la
pandémie covin nous avions échangé
d'éviter que la démocratie soit mise
entre parenthèses de rappeler sa relève
des prérogatives du parlement en
l'occurrence le parlement européen il a
appelé à la responsabilité de chacun
pour que l'urgence ne justifie jamais
que l'on en outre pas ce que l'on prête
avec désinvolture la représentation
parlementaire
comme président du parlement rocla il
fut un homme à l'écouté de l'ensemble
des sensibilités politiques représentés
y compris les plus éloignés de la sienne
en témoignent les dommages à la suite de
sa disparition en provenance de tous les
états membres de toutes les sensibilités
politiques
était un européen de conviction issu de
la vieille europe passionnément italien
c'est à dire pétri d'une histoire
européenne il a incarné ce qui nous unit
la démocratie l'état de droit et les
droits de la personne mais aussi cette
culture en partage à la fois
évidente est si difficile
à définir dans lesquels les européens
avec chacun leurs spécificités
leurs identités se reconnaissent partout
chez eux au sein de l'union du nord au
sud d'est en ouest
c'était un homme courageux qui a tenu à
exercer ses responsabilités jusqu'au
bout malgré la maladie sa détermination
susi a forcé l'admiration
alors que nous entamons la présidence
française de l'union européenne dans son
volet parlementaire par la réunion à
partir de demain au sénat de la
conférence des organes spécialisés dans
les affaires communautaires à cauzac
j'ai souhaité que le sénat lui rendent
hommage
je vous remercie
l'ordre du jour appelle questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
notre séance et
retransmissions public sénat sur notre
site internet
chacun sera attentif au respect des uns
et des autres et à celui du temps de
parole
je donne la parole à free bonnecarrère
pour le groupe de l'union centriste
[Applaudissements]
mais le président madame la ministre
chers collègues notre nation lutte
contre la pandémie du coville 19 elle
est exposée à une autre pandémie le
risque d'une pandémie démocratique ou
présidentielle nul ne saurait s'en
satisfaire notre pays a pris des mesures
pour les élections municipales et avec
le recul de cette expérience pour les
élections départementales et régionales
quelles sont les mesures prises
pour l'élection centrale pour les
élections présidentielles afin de
faciliter les opérations électorales et
de permettre une vraie campagne à
l'instant présent chers collègues il n'y
en a pas et un comité de pilotage aussi
sympathiques ou qualitatif et qu'il soit
ne saurait en tenir lieu en l'état de la
circulation du virus une vraie campagne
nous le percevons tous passera par
l'audiovisuel par les télévisions par
les débats très peu objectivement par
des meetings ou distribution de
propagande
nous ne pouvons pas traiter ce sujet par
voie d'amendement sur le texte vaccinale
que nous sommes en train d'examiner
puisque vous le savez tous l'élection
présidentielle obéit à des dispositions
organiques ma question est donc la
suivante
allez vous madame la ministre allez vous
mesdames messieurs les membres du
gouvernement déposé un projet de loi
organique dans quel délai avec quel
contenu pour éviter une pandémie de la
démocratie
la parole est à
la milice délégué en charge de la
citoyenneté mme hadad marlène schiappa
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs un monsieur le sénateur
élection du président de la république
c'est toujours un moment démocratique
majeur pour notre pays qui est régie par
un cadre juridique spécifique vous le
savez parfaitement dans la mesure où
nous avons ensemble votée récemment la
loi qui permet l'organisation de ces
élections nous avons déjà vécu en 2020
en 2021 la pandémie de caugé 19 ayant eu
d incidence sur l'organisation des
élections elle aura aussi bien sûr des
incidences sur l'organisation
d'élections présidentielles sur la
campagne électorale mais aussi sur les
opérations de vote mais nous veillerons
à faire en sorte qu'elles se déroulent
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
en permettant la plaie l'expression des
candidats mais aussi le meilleur accès
de chaque citoyen à la campagne
électorale c'est d'ailleurs pour cette
raison que le premier ministre jean
castex avec le ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin on fêtait la mise en
place d'une instance de dialogue et de
liaison qui mettent autour de la table
en forme des services de l'état les
partis politiques les candidats déclarés
à l'élection présidentielle pour que les
questions qui seront suscité par les
incidences de la pandémie sur
l'organisation de l'élection
présidentielle puisse être puisse être
traité par don de façon collective et
dans un esprit de responsabilité
partagée les travaux de ce comité
liaison ils seront pilotées par une
personnalité indépendante monsieur jean
denis combrexelle
et cette commission aura vocation à
traiter les aspects strictement
sanitaire touchant à l'élection
présidentielle le comité liaison va
élaborer dans ce cadre un vade-mecum un
protocole spécifique aux réunions
politiques comme d'ailleurs cela avait
déjà été fait en 2021 il abordera aussi
la question des protocoles sanitaires
dans les bureaux de vote et je veux
terminer en remerciant toutes les
personnes qui font vivre la démocratie
en tenant les bureaux de vote lors de
chaque élection le ministère de
l'intérieur organise les élections et
c'est grâce à ces personnes et notamment
aux élus et aux bénévoles qu'elles
peuvent se tenir là je les salue merci
monsieur bonnecarrère
vie a sans doute donné délai alors qu'il
ya une urgence n'est pas convenable dans
ces conditions notre groupe proposera
aux autres groupes du sénat de nous
concerter sur une proposition de loi
organique afin de traiter notamment la
question de la double procuration du
dédoublement des bureaux de vote
lorsqu'ils sont chargés et surtout de
prévoir des obligations spécifiques pour
ouvrir un espace suffisant de débat sur
les médias télévisuels
donner la parole notre collègue charles
avec pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologistes parole
chers collègues merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
dans ce contexte de pandémie
l'école est un véritable enjeu
l'école est un lieu sensible l'école
maternelle est un lieu d'apprentissage à
la socialisation ce qui rend impossible
physiquement l' isolement des élèves et
où le respect de tous les gestes
barrière l'école peut donc aussi être un
lieu de propagation de la pandémie
ce que nous savions nous ne savions pas
il ya 18 mois nous le savons mieux
aujourd'hui au moment où nous vivons
cette cinquième vague de la pandémie dès
l'instant que vous avez fait le choix de
maintenir ouvertes les écoles comment ne
pas comprendre le vaste mouvement social
unitaire qui se prépare pour demain les
revendications des enseignants et de
tous ceux qui environnent l'école sont
justifiées et les associations de
parents d'élèves les soutiennent comment
ne pas comprendre ce message au moment
où la situation devient intenable dans
nos écoles dans les familles et dans nos
collectivités ce dont il est question
aujourd'hui si nous conservons l'école
ouverte c'est de mettre en perspective
une nouvelle approche de ce sujet pour
les deux ou trois années à venir cela
devrait appeler le gel immédiat des
suppressions de postes d'enseignants
c'est qu'il ne semble pas être le cas au
regard des cartes scolaires qui se
prépare cela devrait appeler des
recrutements nouveau pour assurer le
remplacement dans les classes cela
devrait appeler une ambition nouvelle
pour le développement de la médecine
scolaire cela devrait enfin appelé une
politique de soutien à des
investissements de nouveau avec les
collectivités pour installer par exemple
des purificateurs d'air dans les classes
pouvez vous monsieur le ministre nous
dire qu'elle suit vous entendez donner à
ces revendicatif
pour vous répondre la parole et au
ministre de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse et des sports monsieur blanc
caire vous avez la parole merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
j'adhère monsieur le sénateur a au début
de votre question vous avez tout à fait
raison de rappeler à quel point l'enjeu
de l'école ouverte est un enjeu de santé
publique autant que d'éducation pour nos
enfants parce qu'il ya un enjeu de
bien-être psychologique c'est par
exemple la société française de
pédiatrie qui souligne cela depuis le
début et finalement au bout de deux ans
il ya une sorte de consensus qui
n'existait pas au début tu y es là pour
le faire et vous avez raison aussi il
faut le faire à certaines conditions
bien sûr beaucoup de choses ont été
faites pour que l'école ouverte puisse
exister et finalement nous étions
arrivés à une régulation qui
fonctionnait encore au mois de décembre
il a été exact d'affirmer que le nouveau
variant créer une réalité nouvelle avec
une contamination beaucoup plus forte
réalité que connaissent aussi les autres
pays européens pour cela vous le savez
les décision qu'on a prise c'était
d'abord avoir ajouté à au test initial
qui existait déjà en décembre deux autos
tests et nous l'avons fait à la lumière
de ce qu'a dit le haut conseil à la
santé publique aujourd'hui j'entends les
demandes qui existent par rapport à ça
le premier ministre a entendu aussi les
complexités que l'on a bien vu la
semaine dernière pour notamment les
queues devant les pharmacies et celui ci
a abouti à une nouvelle mesure qui est
d'avoir trois auto test
cette nouvelle réalité permet d'assurer
une sécurité sanitaire en même temps que
l'objectif l'école ouverte bien sûr nous
pouvons il ya d'autres choses à faire
vous avez accentuer la question des
postes je rappelle qu'au début du mois
de janvier la première inquiétude
formulée par les uns les autres c'est
est ce qu'on va être capable de
remplacer les professeurs qui serait
malade eh bien nous l'avons fait pour
l'essentiel et nous l'avons faire en
faisant des recrutements c'est à la
hauteur de 6000 e tp que nous avons au
muscle et nos vivier de remplacement et
pour l'instant cela fonctionne autrement
dit nous n'avons pas de d'énormes
problèmes de remplacement même s'il y en
a je me suis d'ailleurs exprimé ici sur
ce point pour d'autres sujets budgétaire
que vous avez évoquées je veux vous
rassurer monsieur le sénateur regardez
le budget 2022 je vous rappelle que
l'augmentation du budget de l'éducation
nationale sous ce quinquennat et la plus
forte qu'on ait connu et notamment plus
forte que le précédent quinquennat et
donc il n'y a pas de suppressions de
postes prévues et sur l'ensemble du
quinquennat encore une fois c'est une
augmentation de 13 % du budget qui nous
permet de face à différents faire face à
différents problèmes dont celui du
remplacement je vous remercie
quelques secondes monsieur l'est si vous
le souhaitez
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre évidemment la situation appelle
beaucoup d'humilité de modestie elle
appelle aussi beaucoup de solennité et
le respect je dirais des revendications
qui s'expose il faut que les réponses
sont à la hauteur des enjeux l'école à
des besoins nouveaux sachant relever
ensemble des filles mes filles la parole
est maintenant notre collègue dominique
qui au fil pour le gros bout des
rassemblements des démocrates pour régis
et indépendant vous avez la parole vous
chers collègues mesdames et messieurs
les ministres monsieur le président mes
chers collègues madame la ministre
2 depuis deux ans nous vivons avec l'aco
vite 19 alors que la majorité des
français a fait preuve d'une grande
responsabilité dans la lutte contre la
propagation du virus la radicalisation
d'une minorité est incontestable donc on
s'attend avec gravité que près de 1200
maires parlementaires et autres élus ont
été pris pour cible en 2021
malheureusement le début de l'année 2022
n'est pas en reste dernier exemple en
date l'agression dimanche dernier du
député de saint pierre et miquelon
stéphane cléo devant son domicile par
des manifestants opposés au pass
vaccinale les intimidations les menaces
les actes de violence doivent être
condamnées et combattues avec force au
risque d'être banalisé ces comportements
intolérables ne concerne pas nos seuls
élus les soignants les professionnels
engagés jour et nuit pour sauver les
vies enfants aussi les frais lettres de
menaces centres de vaccination tagués et
vandalisé quand ils ne sont pas criblé
de balles comme à nyon dans la drôme
violence verbale violence physique est
également sur mon territoire la
guadeloupe le 4 janvier dernier le
directeur du chu de pointe à pitre gira
côté long et son adjoint ont été
séquestrés
et frappé vendredi dernier c'est le
responsable du centre de vaccination de
monster dans le haut rhin qui a été
agressé à la sortie de son établissement
madame la ministre la montée de la
violence à laquelle nous assistons doit
être fermement combattu aussi madame
l'anis
quelles sont les mesures immédiates que
le gouvernement entend prendre pour
éviter qu'un drame irréparable ne se
produise je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole et à la minus de
lévis en charge
la parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur dominique théophile
d'abord je veux aller dans le sens de
votre question et commencé par adresser
le plein soutien du gouvernement à
l'ensemble des élus qui sont agressés ou
menacés bien évidemment l'ensemble des
élus de tous les bords politiques et de
tous les territoires de la république
parce que oui être élu c'est d'abord
s'engager pour les autres quelle qu'en
soit l'instance quel que soit le mandat
et je veux saluer cet engagement qui est
au coeur de la démocratie au coeur de la
citoyenneté je veux d'ailleurs ici
rappeler que la grande majorité des élus
locaux sont bénévoles dans leur commune
et en ma qualité de ministre a chargé de
la citoyenneté je peux 4 bien sûr
sensible alerte que vous partagez que
nous sommes nombreux à partager sur
l'augmentation substantielle des
agressions qui cible les élus et je veux
partager les chiffres du ministère de
l'intérieur avec vous au cours des onze
derniers mois des 11 premiers mois
pardon de l'année 2021 les violences
contre les élus ont augmenté de 47% les
outrageante augmenté de 30% ce sont 160
deux parlementaires et 605 maires ou
adjoints qui ont été victimes
d'atteintes volontaires à l'intégrité
physique jeu c'est l'engagement sincère
et puissant de la chambre haute à
l'égard de nos élus le gouvernement bien
évidemment le partage et je veux dire
que derrière ces chiffres il ya des
réalités des vies et des vies qu'ils
font vivre la démocratie et je crois que
défendre l'intégrité des élus est
fondamental le débat oui la controverse
oui la violence la menace jamais alors
monsieur le sénateur vous mettez aussi
en avant la situation des soignants qui
depuis 2010 flûte avec acharnement
contre la pandémie mondiale je ne peux
que vous rejoindre il est honteux de
voir nos soignants qui sont mobilisés
agresser je veux dire qu'en guadeloupe
particulièrement département de vous
êtes élu ce sont 200 forces de sécurité
intérieure supplémentaire que le
ministère de l'intérieur dépêche sur
place pour mieux assurer la sécurité de
tous et de tout partout sur le
territoire l'état est présent aux côtés
de tous les citoyens et je veux dire que
nous faisons face à une situation
sanitaire complexe inédite que c'est
ensemble que nous en sortirons et que le
gouvernement croyez le bien est
pleinement mobilisé y compris avec de
nouveaux dispositifs pour toujours mieux
protéger les élus je vous remercie je
théophile
[Musique]
vous avez quelques secondes
juste une phrase il faut que cela cesse
donner la parole à notre collègue
hussein bourgi pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste bobital
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale monsieur le
ministre depuis dix jours la communauté
éducative est confronté à une situation
particulièrement préoccupante et
éprouvante elle découle de la
multiplication de protocoles visant à
gérer la crise sanitaire ce qui pose
problème c'est certes la propagation du
virus mais aussi le caractère tardif de
vos instructions et devon revirement la
conséquence est qu une grève qui
s'annonce particulièrement suivi aura
lieu demain pouvez vous nous dire
monsieur le ministre quelle est la
genèse de cette situation chaotique à
laquelle les élèves les parents les
enseignants et les élus locaux sont
confrontés pouvez vous nous indiquer
monsieur le ministre quelles sont les
réponses aux inquiétudes légitimes et au
mécontentement réel qui vont s'exprimer
demain pour dénoncer les adéquations des
protocoles car ils épuisent les
enseignants comme les familles pouvez
vous me dire monsieur le ministre que
vous comptez faire pour restaurer la
sérénité dans ce climat particulièrement
anxiogène est préjudiciable pour les
enfants comme pour les enseignants je
vous remercie pour vous répondre je
parole à monsieur le premier ministre
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur merci pour votre
question qui me donne l'occasion de
revenir sur la gestion de la crise
sanitaire en général et sur la situation
en milieu scolaire en particulier qui
évidemment doit susciter toute notre
attention je voudrais monsieur le
président indiqué par rapport à la
question qui a été posée
quelle est la situation qui nous a
conduits à prendre les décisions que
nous avons prises je veux le faire avec
le maximum de sérénité possible cela a
été dit à la question présente tout le
monde le sait nous sommes confrontés la
france leur amplement d'un nouveau
variant omicron qui a des
caractéristiques spécifiques on le sait
à peu près maintenant il est beaucoup
plus contagieux sans doute on l'espère
on le pense on le mesure un peu moins
contagieux que le variant delta qui l'a
beaucoup remplacez
qu'il a beaucoup remplacer mais pas
encore complètement
bien à partir de quoi la première des
réponses vous le savez plus que jamais
c'est la vaccination puisqu'on sait tous
les sénateurs sont parfaitement au
courant notamment qu'avec un schéma
vaccinal complet et la dose de rappel
on peut contracter omikron il n'y a pas
de problème c'est connu on le sait mais
on est moins contagieux et surtout
surtout on a infiniment moins de chance
d'avoir des formes graves il faut ou de
risques vous avez raison il faut le
répéter à nos concitoyens dont la
vaccination pardonnez-moi la vaccination
reste larmes centrale et et vous me
permettrez monsieur le président de
rappeler évidemment ici l'importance qui
s'attache à l'adoption du texte sur le
pass vaccinale qui est en train de
discuter la hante a semblé bien mais
mais nous avons dû aussi et c'est la
source
des difficultés que nous avons
adapté notre politique de dépistage
cette politique de dépistage de test
depuis le début de la pandémie elle
repose sur des avis des autorités
scientifiques et sanitaires et c'est
heureux et non aux autorités
scientifiques et sanitaire monsieur le
sénateur sur l'évolution principale de
la doctrine de dépistage se sont
prononcés c'est comme ça le 31 décembre
pourquoi cette date d'abord on va vous
répondre le le virus ne connaît pas de
vacances il est fait ces autorités non
plus pourquoi parce qu'elle avait besoin
de recul sur ce qui s'est passé sur les
pays qui étaient en avance de phase
notamment au sud de l'afrique et en
grande bretagne donc élevé si nous avons
reçu un protocole c'est à dire c'est pas
les atermoiements du gouvernement c'est
l'évolution de la doctrine sanitaire
fait par les autorités habilitées et qui
nous dit quoi et c'est assez logique et
nous dit
évidemment quand on n'est qu'à positif
depuis le début ça ça n'a pas changé on
doit s'isoler simplement compte tenu des
caractéristiques tôt mikron elle nous
dit si vous avez un schéma vaccinal
complet et c'est heureux de distinguer
c'est notre politique ceux qui sont
vaccinées de ceux qui ne le sont pas
la durée de l'isolément se trouve
réduite et par ailleurs les cas
contactez enfants ou adultes en tout cas
pour les adultes qui ont un schéma
vaccinal cesse et l'innovation
on ne s'isole plus
mais en revanche on se teste davantage
tant que là où il fallait un test il en
faut trois jeux si ça vous fait sourire
manche bien c'est pas un problème c'est
d'ailleurs le cas de tous les pays qui
nous entourent c'est le cas de tous les
pays qui nous entourent oh ce test
davantage et c'est donc mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs ce qu'à l'école
comme ailleurs nous appliquons sec
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a l'école comme
ailleurs nous appliquons
avec un certain alors je le dis oh pas
lorsque j'entends dire il faudrait
réduire le testeur les mêmes qui nous
disait avant noël il faut les rendre
gratuits les augmenter il ne faut pas
réduire les tests il ne faut pas réduire
l'aide ailleurs je me vous donner un
chiffre aujourd'hui je disais que la
france était parmi les pays qui testait
le plus ou moins que c'est encore plus
vrai parce que cette semaine grâce soit
rendue à tous ceux qui concourent à cet
effort collectif
nous serons sur une augmentation de 27 %
c'est-à-dire qu'on devait sur une
moyenne hebdomadaire de 12 bull 1
million de tests cet inédit et je pense
qu'on peut rendre hommage aux
laboratoires aux pharmaciens tous les
professionnels qui teste des enfants
comme des adultes j'en profite pour dire
à l'art par la haute assemblée vous y
serez sensible monsieur le président que
je l'avais déjà annoncé lors d'un
déplacement à rosny en fin de semaine
dernière voyant les que qu'il y avait
seriez oui bah oui il faut tester
beaucoup d'hommes cadets que c'est vrai
on a accru on a cru la fourniture des
tests et des autotests oui là aussi à
une tension mondial sur le marché des
autotests mai 11 millions gelé déjà
déclaré 11 millions vont être sont en
cours de livraison dans toutes nos
pharmacies cet ailleurs plusieurs
questions de bras souvent qu'une
question de produits c'est les deux donc
je les dis à ces dernières je vois des
initiatives nous les encourageons de
maires d'élus locaux tiraient ouvre
comme ils sont mobilisés sur la
vaccination des centres de test y
compris pourquoi pas comme je les dis en
seine saint denis à côté des écoles je
veux dire à la haute assemblée que non
seulement nous souhaitons nous
favorisons mais que nous débloquerons
tous les moyens financiers pour
accompagner ce mouvement de déploiement
de centres de test que ce soit clair
mais ça concerne les écoles mais ça
parce que à l'école évidemment ce qui
pose question outre les allègements du
protocole que j'ai déjà annoncé se
sentent aussi les que que faisaient les
enfants et leurs parents dans les
pharmacies et auquel
non mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
nous avons écouté moi je sais bien que
les heures s'auto polémique et c'est
tout ça je l'entends parfaite pas j'ai
l'habitude rassurez vous notre politique
c'est celle là en vacciner on teste
l'alternative je termine là dessus
monsieur présent l'alternative c'est
quoi c'est la fermeture des écoles de
l'économie et ça et je suis sûr que nous
sommes largement unanime nous ne voulons
pas monsieur bourgi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur le premier ministre je vous
remercie de m'avoir fait l'honneur de
répondre à ma question était toujours
avec beaucoup d'intérêt et de vous
respect que je vous écoute même lorsque
vous me tourner le dos
je voulais vous dire monsieur le premier
ministre que les propos que vous venez
de tenir ce sont ceux que vous avez tenu
hier à l'assemblée nationale que j'ai
écouté aussi avec beaucoup d'intérêt je
regrette que vous n'ayez pas mesuré la
gravité de la situation
je regrette que vous donniez le
sentiment d'être finalement déconnecté
des réalités et dépassé par les
événements je regrette finalement à
travers votre question cette réalité que
vous venez de fraude offrir aux
françaises et aux français c'est que le
programme le ministre de l'éducation
nationale a rendu les armes devant le
virus je vais répondre aux éléments de
réponse que vous avez apporté vous nous
indiquer que la première réponse c'est
la vaccination et monsieur le premier
ministre la proposition que le groupe
socialiste a fait depuis plusieurs mois
l'obligation vaccinale
deuxième élément de réponse monsieur le
premier ministre vous louez ce évoqué
l'aide le dépistage monsieur le premier
ministre je vous propose de mobiliser
les forces de la sécurité civile afin
qu'ils aillent dans les écoles épauler
les équipes éducatives afin que le
dépistage se fasse dans les écoles et
enfin je répondrai par un troisième
élément une question le gouvernement
l'utile contre l'épidémie où l'utile
contre la gestion ou pour la gestion de
la diffusion du virus par une immunité
collective le jour où vous aurez répondu
à cette question peut-être que vous
serez davantage écoutés et compris par
le parlementaire et par les français
pharand les cas notre collègue ghislaine
pantel pour le goal du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen parole
ridha monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre chers collègues depuis des
semaines et de prix de l'énergie et des
carburants augmentent plus 41% pour le
gas 21 pour les carburants 3 % pour
l'électricité
ces hausses ont conduit fin 2021 un
surcroît de dépenses mensuelles en
énergie de 30 euros en moyenne par
ménage par rapport à fin 2010 9
les habitants des zones rurales et ip
rurales sont extrêmement concernés par
ces dépenses au regard des
particularités géographiques et
climatiques de nos territoires au coeur
du massif central des diversions rude
les besoins en chauffage ils sont bien
souvent plus importants qu'ailleurs en
lozère sur la margeride ou dans les
cévennes le véhicule personnel est
indispensable au quotidien pour
accompagner des enfants à la crèche à
l'école pour se rendre au travail un
entretien d'embauché ou chez un médecin
une fois de plus ces augmentations sont
vécus comme une double peine par nos
concitoyens car elle s'ajoute à la perte
de services publics de proximité et à
l'absence de solutions de mobilité au
quotidien
oui monsieur le ministre les habitants
de balsièges b2s occurrence saint pierre
le vieux ou pourcharesses doivent
prendre leur véhicule pour acheter leur
pain c'est la réalité de nos territoires
le quotidien des français par ailleurs
pour faire à face à l'inflation le
premier ministre a annoncé une prime
exceptionnelle de 100 euros et la baisse
de la taxe intérieure sur la
consommation finale d'électricité
cependant vous en conviendrez ces
dispositifs ne permettront pas de
compenser la hausse des tarifs sur
l'année et notamment celle de
l'électricité qui pourrait être de 40 %
au 1er février prochain
alors monsieur le ministre vous l'aurez
compris ma question est la suivante
comment comptez vous protéger le pouvoir
d'achat des ménages sur le long terme et
lutter contre la flambée des prix et
quelles mesures spécifiques entre vous
pour la ruralité car notre république
doit être présente aux côtés de tous ses
citoyens y compris ceux des territoires
ruraux merci
répondre la parole est aux bilans chef
des comptes publics je dis cela ils
avaient la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice pantel vous interroger le
gouvernement vous interroger sur les
questions du pouvoir d'achat et
notamment la question du pouvoir d'achat
face à la flambée des prix de l'énergie
votre question me permet à la fois de
rappeler ce qui a été fait nous avons
diminué les impôts de 25 milliards
d'euros sur les ménages
avec la baisse de l'impôt sur le revenu
la taxe d'habitation nous avons
revalorisé les revenus du travail par la
prime d'activité ou encore les minima
sociaux je pense au minimum vieillesse
ou encore l'allocation adulte handicapé
toutes ces mesures ont permis baisses
d'impôts augmentation de revenu
d'augmenter le pouvoir d'achat des
ménages de 8% l'échelle du quinquennat
soit une augmentation deux fois plus
rapide que les dix années précédentes
cela se heurte aujourd'hui à une réalité
vous avez décrite l'augmentation des
prêts l'énergie non pas en france mais
partout dans le monde en europe et dans
le monde le gouvernement a réagi après
un certain nombre de dispositions la
première des dispositions que nous avons
prises visent les ménages les plus
défavorisés et le premier ministre avait
annoncé il ya quelques semaines cela
était évidemment réalisé depuis le
versement d'un chèque énergie
supplémentaire de 100 euros pour cinq
millions huit cent mille ménages nous
avons aussi mis en place une indemnité
inflation avec la volonté d'aider tous
les ménages tous les français est
gagnant moins de 2000 euros net par mois
qu'il soit conducteur au nom d'un
véhicule mais pour les aider à faire
face à l'augmentation des prix et pas
seulement des prix des carburants cette
indemnité va bénéficier à 38 millions de
personnes les versements sont en cours
selon le calendrier que nous avons
arrêtés et par exemple le 20 janvier
prochain la caf va verser cette
indemnité inflation à 3 millions de
ménages et puis nous avons pris les
dispositions qui le parlement a bien
voulu voter pour plafonner
l'augmentation du prix l'électricité à
4% depuis le mois d'octobre 2021 et
plafonner l'augmentation du prix du gaz
au même montant que celui d'octobre 2021
ces dispositifs sont actifs ils ont été
validés par le conseil constitutionnel
et le gouvernement les actifs les
utilisent pour limiter l'augmentation du
prix de l'énergie nous le faisons et
cela un coup cela peut représenter
plusieurs milliards d'euros par an nous
le faisons aussi parce que nous
connaissons la situation vous avez
décrite je suis moi même élu en ardèche
ardéchois de naissance je sais trop
combien usage d'un véhicule à deux roues
à quatre roues est nécessaire pour le
quotidien et la nécessité qu'il ya
d'accompagner les ménages les plus
fragiles face à cette flambée des prix
de l'énergie
n'importe quel les quelques secondes
quelques secondes merci monsieur le
ministre b g système dassault sur la
nécessité d'être particulière aux
territoires ruraux et hyperburo merci
merci bien la parole est à notre
collègue daniel seulement pour le groupe
écologie solidarité territoire
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre parlons cannabis après des
années de flou le gouvernement précise
enfin la réglementation autour du cbd en
interdisant par arrêté la vente des
fleurs et des feuilles brut de chambre
contenant ce cbd la molécule non
psychotropes du cannabis
cette politique prohibitifs dont la
faillite est évidente amène des milliers
de personnes qui se trouvent dans la
fleur qui trouve dans la fleur de
chandra substitue au cannabis à se
tourner vers les dealers au risque de
leur santé prouvant une nouvelle fois
que le combat pour la santé des
consommateurs n'a jamais été votre
objectif un vrai cadeau aux trafiquants
alors que tant de nos concitoyens
trouble dans ce produit de vraies vertus
apaisantes et relaxante dans une société
toujours plus sous tension où la
consommation d'anxiolytiques trice des
records voulait renvoyer dans
l'illégalité enfin vous freiner le
développement d'une filière de chant
prometteuse qui répondent aux attentes
sociétales et environnementales
elle permettrait de développer tout le
potentiel extraordinaire de cette plante
complexe et plein d'atouts nos
agriculteurs ne vous remercie pas en
faisant prospérer la philosophie de
l'interdît celle là même qui a perdu
devant nombre de jeudi réduction de la
cour de justice de l'union européenne à
la cour de cassation et peut être demain
devant le conseil d'état vous mettez en
évidence la vision étroite que vous avez
du sujet prisonniers que vous êtes de
votre vision de politique de répression
inefficace et dangereuse contre le
cannabis nous sommes les leaders
européens du chanvre et nous allons
prendre un retard considérable surtout
nos voisins européens notamment
allemands dont le pragmatisme tranche
avec notre dogmatisme paternaliste et
contreproductif si la loi française
interdit toute drogue à l'exception de
certaines comme le tabac ou l'alcool
rappelons le cbd n'est ni un stupéfiant
ni un produit nocif pour la santé
alors monsieur le ministre allez vous
revenir sur ces décrets ubuesque
interdisant le cbd comme l'ont fait la
grande majorité de nos voisins européens
merci pour vous répondre la parole et
des solidarités de la santé monsieur
libérant vous avez la parole
mesdames mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur merci pour cette
question monsieur le sénateur daniel
salmon pardonnez moi merci pour votre
question qui pèse sur la culture du
chanvre est un peu plus généralement sur
la consommation de cbd ah bon vous dire
que la france a autorisé et confirmé
l'autorisation par un arrêté publié le
31 décembre dernier qu'il était possible
de cultiver du chanvre dans notre pays
et vous avez raison de souligner c'est
un enjeu agricole industriel important
pour notre pays on parle beaucoup du
chanvre en ce qu'il pourrait concerner
une forme de consommation mais en
réalité le chanvre est surtout utilisé
dans des isolations par exemple
thermique ou de à bien d'autres usages
et nous souhaitons qu'ils puissent être
cultivée qui puisse être commercialisé
et nous souhaitons soutenir dans la
durée la filière agricole de chambre
dans notre pays l'autre question c'est
est ce qu'on peut aller est ce qu'il
faut aller au delà ce qu'il faut
autoriser le chambre cette fois ci à
titre de consommation alors pour la
question du avec le chanvre peut avoir
deux produits qui sont considérés comme
psychoactifs le cbd le thc le th est ce
qui donne les effets euphorisants
recherchés par les consommateurs de
drogues le cbd est un peu borderline si
vous me permettez l'expression considéré
comme ayant des effets relaxants
certains lui prêtent des vocations
thérapeutiques attention la loi interdit
de traiter des vocations thérapeutiques
ou cbd qui en a aucune reconnue
scientifiquement et pour certains lui
prêtent des vertus de relaxation etc la
consommation ça reste mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs un produit qui
de fait se fume or fumer c'était pas bon
pour la santé donc d'un point de vue
sanitaire il a été considéré que la
consommation de cbd ne devait pas être
autorisé à usage individuel que ce soit
d'ailleurs sous forme directe de
feuilles et de fleurs qui peuvent être
vendus dans certaines boutiques mais
également sous forme dévié on en
trouvait dans des pots pourris ou dans
des tisanes chacun sait ce que les gens
pouvaient en faire c'est donc là ce que
prévoit cet arrêté publié au 31 décembre
on encourage la culture de chance dans
notre pays pas sa consommation à titre
individuel
socialement quelques secondes
le manuel macron s'était présenté sous
le costume da libérales modernes en fait
c'est un jeune conservateur un type
fillon 2 non
j'ai donné la parole à notre collègue
vanina paoli gaza
pour le plus indépendant et voulait des
territoires vous avez la parole
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mais chaque collègue le ministre de la
santé vient de répondre sur le volet
santé publique de ma question qui
concerne également la filière cbd qui a
commencé et 2022 sous de sombres
auspices avec cet arrêté gouvernemental
du 31 décembre qui interdit en france la
vente aux consommateurs de fleurs ou de
faits bruts ou sous toute forme seul ou
mélangés il a pourtant permis des
avancées comme ça a été évoqué ça
représente néanmoins un coup d'arrêt
brutal pour tout un écosystème où se
croisent grand producteur de chanvre
comme dans mon département dans l'aube
petits paysans qui ont diversifié leurs
productions et jeunes entrepreneurs qui
ont pris des risques pour ouvrir leurs
boutiques ce marché c'est un milliard
d'euros des millions de consommateurs
comme le rappelait mon collègue des
milliers d'emplois ces français ne sont
pas accrocs cbd bien d'être ce n'est pas
parce qu'ils prennent une tisane au cbd
le soir qui vont devenir des junkies
l'argument sanitaire peine donc à
convaincre
la consommation d'anxiolytiques qui a
explosé avec la crise sanitaire concerne
plus d'un français sur quatre voilà sans
doute un vrai sujet de santé publique
qui mérite l'attention
la position de la cour de justice de
l'union européenne était pourtant très
clair aligné sur la doctrine de l' oms
avec des taux de thc inférieure à 0 3 %
le cbd n'est pas un stupéfiant donc une
régulation est nécessaire mais d'autres
moyens existent est pourquoi ne pas
avoir renforcé le processus de contrôle
des producteurs les chanvriers qui sont
soumis à un haut niveau d'exigence
trouve comme c'est le cas dans l'aube
que c'est possible et la france reste le
premier producteur européen
le feuilleton juridique français
continuent pendant ce temps nos voisins
européens accélèrent nous serons bientôt
inonder de produits issus de pays qui ne
devise pas sur les feuilles et les
fleurs comme nous en avons seul le grand
art madame la ministre quelle est votre
stratégie pour soutenir l'écosystème
après l'envoi d'un drôle de signal
pour vous répondre la parole et de rémy
nice délégué en charge l'industrie va
l'amener chez
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice vannini paoli gaza à la suite
d'une commission d'une décision de la
cour de justice de l'union européenne
les autorités françaises ont révisé la
réglementation applicable à la culture
l'importation et l'utilisation du
chanvre par un arrêté du 30 décembre
ce nouveau cadre réglementaire je veux
le préciser s'il maintient au niveau de
protection des consommateurs est prêt et
préserve notre politique ambitieuse de
lutte contre les trafics de stupéfiants
comme l'a très bien expliqué le ministre
véran permet aussi de sécuriser le
développement économique de nouvelles
activités liées à la culture et à la
production d'extraits et la
commercialisation de produits qui en
intègre simplement on en précise les
règles cet arrêté c'est donc une chance
pour la filière qui est aujourd'hui la
première européenne et qui dispose de
grands donneurs d'ordres intéressés pour
ses produits dans la cosmétique par
exemple ou dans l'agroalimentaire c'est
un marché qui représente 700 millions
d'euros et 15000 emplois
l'interdiction que vous mentionnez une
porte que sur les fleurs et les feuilles
qui ne peuvent être récoltées importé
utilisé que pour une production
industrielle et à les justifier je vais
pas revenir sur les arguments qui ont
été développés par le ministre de la
santé est un produit psychoactif dans
les feuilles et les fleurs bien malin
qui est capable au premier coup d'oeil
de mesurer le taux de thc et bien malin
aussi qui s'effeuillent et ses fleurs
elles ont tendance à plus concentré
c'est pour des raisons donc de
protection du consommateur et de lutte
contre les stupéfiants que cette
réglementation était prise je veux
préciser deux choses la première chose
c'est que la commission européenne a
validé cette recette réglementation donc
il n'y a pas je dirais de retour en
arrière par rapport à la décision de la
cour de justice européenne la deuxième
chose vous avez raison de mentionner que
se passe-t-il par rapport à la
concurrence d'autres pays il nous tenons
une position au niveau française pour
précisément avoir une réglementation qui
soit commune à l'ensemble des pays
européens ce qui permettrait de répondre
à votre préoccupation utilise beaucoup
mais aussi la parole et
à jean-françois ution pour le groupe
l'est républicain sur un compteur
général
madame la ministre les ménages les
entreprises les collectivités locales
vois tu arrives et une hausse très
importante estimé même à plus de 40 %
des tarifs de des prix d'électricité
avec deux conséquences majeures pour les
tarifs réglementés qui concernent les
particuliers et les petites entreprises
vous n'arriverez à tenir l'engagement
que vous avez pris en septembre visant à
limiter la hausse à 4 % compris d'une
facture considérable pour nos finances
publiques c'est un chèque de plus pour
l'ensemble des autres entreprises et
pour les collectivités territoriales la
hausse fulgurante des prix de
l'électricité sera très loin d'être
compensée par la baisse de la fiscalité
plus parce que man de la tcf e induisant
de fait une diminution pour ces
entreprises de leur compétitivité et de
leurs capacités d'investissement madame
la ministre commente allez vous garantir
le maintien du bouclier tarifaire en
2022 et limiter les conséquences de
cette es11 sur les entreprises et les
collectivités à la lumière de ces
nouvelles estimations chant bien sûr
différait l'impact en 2023
[Applaudissements]
elle a mis la transition écologique un
homme qui dit merci monsieur le
président mesdames les sénatrices
métiers du sénateur monsieur de
sénateurs us ont je peux vous le
confirmer effectivement la hausse des
tarifs réglementés de l'électricité sera
bien contenue à 4 % en 2022 c'est un
engagement que nous avons pris nous y
mettons les moyens effectivement
monsieur sénateurs mais nous assumons
nous assumons c'est un coût de 8
milliards c'est un coût de 8 milliards
c'est un coût de 8 milliards mais je
vous rappelle que le coût de l'inaction
si on laissait faire les conséquences
seraient pour notre économie et pour nos
concitoyens beaucoup plus important donc
nous assumons complètement de prendre ce
genre de mesure pour les industriels et
ceux qui ne sont pas soumis aux tarifs
réglementés il y a effectivement une
hausse qui est une hausse qui va être
très différente selon les situations des
entreprises nous sommes en train de
travailler alors bien sûr ils
bénéficieront aussi de la baisse de la
fiscalité mais pour certaines
entreprises ça peut monter et donc nous
sommes en train de travailler à des
dispositifs nous sommes en train
d'aboutir et nous allons annoncer ce
dispositif dans les jours qui viennent
pour pouvoir justement contenir cette
hausse et faire en sorte effectivement
qu'il n'y ait pas de report sur l'année
d'après nous ne voulons pas laisser la
facture pour ceux qui nous suivraient
tout simplement parce que c'est une
question de responsabilité
vous connaissez les outils qui sont à
disposition nous sommes en train d'en
discuter avec la commission de
régulation de l'énergie avec edf et on
vous annoncera les mesures plus tard
mais ce que je peux vous confirmer c'est
que nous sommes mobilisés pour que cette
hausse des prix de l'énergie qui ne sont
pas déniés cesson c'est une hausse
globale qui est sur tous les marchés
notamment le marché européen nous allons
y faire face un dernier point nous
travaillons aussi au niveau de l'union
européenne avec bruno le maire chacun
dans notre filière de négociation pour
travailler avec la commission pour enfin
pouvoir faire évoluer d'un point de vue
du détail de marquette design sur les
prix de l'énergie dont nous avons vu les
limites avec cette crise merci monsieur
huchon
madame la ministre vos réponses et vous
pourrez le dire à bruno le maire tap tap
plutôt à côté d'eux à côté de la cible
parce que en fait sale va satisfaire ni
les particuliers parce qu'ils vont avoir
un impact important sur le pouvoir
d'achat ni les entreprises qui subissent
déjà de plein fouet la hausse des prix
des matières premières et pour lesquels
pour certaines il va y avoir un arrêt de
la production et enfin pour les
collectivités qui subissent lourdement
la conséquence de ces augmentations dans
leur budget de fonctionnement en fait
l'équation à cette crise énergétique n'a
que des solutions perdante à l'heure
actuelle au regard de ce que vous venez
de me dire et puis en fait une triple
faute y ait une faute économique parce
que ça va présenter un coût pour les
finances publiques de l'ordre de 15
milliards d'euros c'est une faute en
ironnement talent parce que vous
remettez une production à base de
centrales nucléaires au charbon faute
d'avoir
depuis bientôt dix ans fait le choix
d'une grille site est décarbonée une
électricité décarbonés qui est un choix
majeur de souveraineté nationale et
enfin c'est une erreur politique
par les choix mais aussi par le coût que
ce que ce déficit de porte sur nos
finances publiques +2 55% déficit
commercial est due à la facture
énergétique
la parole est à nos frais
max brisson pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'éducation nationale le dernier
protocoles sanitaires à l'école le
septième en 18 mois évitez le 2 janvier
appliquez le 3 modifier le fils encadrés
par le préfet le 8 assoupli le dise par
le premier ministre donne l'impression
selon les propos d'une directrice
d'école d'un mauvais jeu de société dans
les règles changent tous les deux jours
en avant ce lundi en recul mercredi et
surtout on n'y comprend plus rien alors
ma question sera très simple monsieur le
ministre pourquoi tant des préparations
pour vous répondre
la parole et hobbies l'éducation
nationale jeunesse et des sports
monsieur bloquèrent
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur brisson le premier
nice vous a déjà en partie répondu en
expliquant la genèse
vous inquiétez pas ça ne m'empêchera pas
de vous répondre si vous me laissez
parler donc d'abord il y a eu un conseil
de défense le lundi qui a précédé la
rentrée le lendemain mardi j'ai indiqué
qu' il y aurait à la fois ouverture des
écoles de lundi suivant et que le
principal changement concernerait le
fait qu'il y aurait un ou plusieurs
tests en plus du test déjà existants les
grandes lignes étaient donc dit ensuite
comme l'a dit le premier ministre le
vendredi soir il y a eu l'avis du haut
conseil de santé publique qui permet
d'avoir tous les détails
préconisé pour avoir une vision
cohérente de la théorie en société
générale en population générale et à
l'école tout ceci est prêt si complexe
et doit être cohérent et a été travaillé
par les autorités dans la journée du 1er
janvier nous avons transposé cela pour
en faire le protocole et ensuite le
ministre de la santé s'est exprimé pour
donner la doctrine en population
générale puis moi même pour la doctrine
sur l'école voilà le déroulé des choses
rappelons que ce le même jour j'ai
diffusé contrairement à ce qu'on dit
parfois sur internet les dents là ce
qu'on appelle la foire aux questions que
vous pouvez toujours consulter tout le
temps sur le site l'ensemble des détails
et quelques minutes plus tard dans un
quotidien pour la population en général
de façon à informer tout ceci bien sûr
nous aimerions que ce soit différent
c'est évident sur ce point comme sur
d'autres nous sommes contraints par des
réalités en l'occurrence nous aimerions
nous préférons qu'il n'y ait pas le
virus nous préférerions qui n'est pas
une telle complexité des choses ensuite
vous avez cherché d'une certaine façon à
caricaturer les évolutions qui sont le
prix à payer pour être au plus près des
réalités mais si on va aller pur des
grands principes c'est toujours le même
il ya comme je le disais tout à l'heure
depuis fin novembre un test à faire au
début pour revenir à l'école et ce qui a
été ajouté début janvier ces deux autos
test la seule transformation c'est celle
que le preuve réelle profonde c'est
celle que le premier ministre a annoncé
c'est à dire que premier test devient un
autotest parce qu'on a justement écouter
les complexités éprouvées par les
acteurs de terrain donc j'en veux créer
des politiques auraient été assez facile
vu les difficultés que pau que pose ce
virus soit on cherche l'unité nationale
autour de notre école et on va vers le
haut et tout simplement décrit les
choses comme elles sont aujourd'hui les
trois autotests permettre d'aller dans
ce sens décrit par le premier ministre
c'est à dire une une politique qui
permet et d'avoir l'école ouverte et
l'avoir de la sécurité sanitaire je vous
remercie
monsieur brisson j'avais la parole
monsieur le ministre et si le fiasco
généralisée de votre gestion de la crise
sanitaire n'était pas plus large des
classements permanent des résultats de
nos élèves dans les enquêtes
internationales recul des savoirs
fondamentaux du lire écrire compter
sortie de route du nouveau baccalauréat
devenu un maquis dans lequel se perdent
les élèves absurdités du calendrier du
contrôle continu qui soumet les lys hier
au stress de l'examen perpétuelle
effondrement de l'enseignement des
mathématiques en lycée pour nous
projeter pourtant le redressement
circulaire caporalisant tzu lesquels
coulent les établissements vous qui
pourtant annonciez pleurs autonomie
voilà c'est qu'aux jeunes professeurs
toujours mal payés mal formés toujours
aussi peu considérée et malmené par un
véritable bizutage institutionnels
démission en masse moral au plus bas
l'attractivité du métier n'a jamais été
aussi faible ils vont nous le dire deux
mers avec force et avec le soutien des
parents et des mères s'il n'y avait à
tout cela parmi les causes une qui vous
incombent et à vous seuls celui d'une
gestion solitaire rejetant tout dialogue
agi sans concertation et finalement
faisant apparaître le bloquer rythme
pour ce qu'il est un autoritarisme
esseulé impliquant largement l'étrange
défaite dans lequel sombre ce
quinquennat en matière d'éducation
la parole est à notre collègue
c'est lui en vert on le vole socialistes
écologistes et républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adressait à la ministre de la culture
et de la communication annulations de
spectacles report de date arrêt des
tournées telle est la situation
difficile du spectacle vivant en ce
début d'année en plus de la cinquième
vague et de ses conséquences les
décisions annoncées en décembre dernier
en l'occurrence le rétablissement des
jauges et l'interdiction des concerts
debout prise sans concertation ont
aggravé les perspectives du secteur
culturel une relance soutenue était
espéré en septembre 2020 malheureusement
ce ne fut qu'une reprise compliquée
marquée par un retour plus que timide du
public la fermeture totale des lieux de
culture pendant plusieurs mois n'y est
peut-être pas pour rien alors par delà
la déception ressentie par tous les
acteurs culturels et que nous partageons
c'est une réelle inquiétude pour
l'avenir certes les aides du
gouvernement et leur prolongation
permettront au secteur de continuer de
résister nous le souhaitons en tout cas
mais monsieur le ministre
ces lieux ne doivent plus être
stigmatisé ils ne sont pas des espaces
de contamination et les professionnels
ont toujours été au rendez-vous et
responsable en proposant et en mettant
en oeuvre des protocoles sanitaires
renforcés
une véritable concertation entre tous
les acteurs est attendue faisons leur
confiance
donnant leur enfin la visibilité qu'il
réclame nombre d'artistes et de
techniciens sont en grande difficulté
aujourd'hui certains n'ayant pas
retrouvé les plateaux depuis plusieurs
mois alors dans ce contexte difficile
l'année blanche des intermittents s'est
arrêté au 31 décembre dernier ma
question sera simple avez vous effectué
une évaluation et allez vous la
prolonger jusqu'à l'été prochain je
remercie
la parole au secrétaire d'état auprès du
premier ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice robert je vous prie d'excuser
l'absence de ma collègue roselyne
bachelot qui est retenu dans le cadre d'
obligations liés à la présidence
française de l'union européenne mais
avec qui je le sais vous travaillez en
confiance au quotidien cette crise et ce
virus a très fortement impacté le
secteur culturel partout dans le monde
parce que nous savons que pour lutter
contre le virus il a fallu il faut
encore à certains égards limiter les
rassemblements essayer le rôle et la
force de la culture que de rassembler et
d'unir les français et par delà la
france d'unir dans le monde entier mais
la france s'est singularisée par son
soutien résolu et continue au secteur
culturel la culture c'est probablement
le premier bénéficiaire du quoi qu'il en
coûte 14 milliards d'euros depuis le
début de cette crise nous n'avons pas à
le regretter c'était nécessaire c'était
essentiel c'est un choix politique
majeure qui a été fait pour permettre au
secteur de tenir lui permettre de
rouvrir parce que grâce à la vaccination
grâce au pass tous ces lieux ont pu
rouvrir il y avait il ya un an jour pour
jour vingt fois moins de cas chaque jour
dans notre pays et pourtant les théâtres
étaient fermés les cinémas étaient
fermés les musées étaient fermés tous
les lieux culturels étaient fermés un an
plus tard il ya vingt fois plus de cas
mais ils sont tous ouverts grâce à la
vaccination et grâce au pass nous avons
effectivement été amenés à devoir
prendre des mesures temporaires et j'en
suis vraiment sur ce mot je dirais même
très temporaire de limitation de jauge
dans un certain nombre de lieux et
notamment en intérieur jusqu'à 2000
personnes évidemment que nous continuons
à accompagner le secteur puisque une
partie du secteur et est impacté par ces
mesures vous l'avez dit roselyne
bachelot et bruno lemerle ont annoncé
d'abord le dispositif coûts fixes pour
les entreprises qui perdent plus de 50%
de leur chiffre d'affaires ensuite
l'activité partielle sans reste à charge
et puis l'activité partielle pour les
intermittents vous en avez pas reparlé
qui en bénéficieront si leurs spectacles
sont annulés nos évaluations puisque
c'était votre question montre que la
grande majorité des intermittents ont pu
reconstituer leur droit à la fin 2021
mais je vous le dis tous auront un filet
de sécurité durant l'année 2022 et nous
réactivons les dispositifs sectoriels
vous le voyez madame la sénatrice nous
tenons à ce que la culture garde sa
juste place au coeur de l'âme de notre
pays
[Applaudissements]
oui donc vous n'avez pas complètement
répondu à ma question ce que je voudrais
vous dire c'est d'arrêter cette
politique de stop and go qui met tout le
tout le monde dans la difficulté
brutalement et qui surtout nuit
finalement à l'efficacité de l'action
publique je pense que le secteur attend
vraiment de la visibilité et un grand
prendre lens pour les mois à venir je
remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue isabelle
raymond pas zéro pour le groupe est
réduite faire
dans la ministre on évalue à presque
5000 le nombre de volontaires européens
en syrie début 2015 le contingent
français était malheureusement plus
importants d'europe occidentale mille
quatre cent soixante trois individus de
nationalité française résidant en france
ont rallié la syrie avec la chute du
califat autoproclamé sa déroute dèche a
laissé derrière lui des combattants
doctrine et enfants adolescents qui ont
suivi des entraînements militaires
intensif une formation au code au
discours de l'état islamique ces enfants
grandis selon les services de
renseignement ils sont une menace réelle
il pourrait constituer une nouvelle
génération de djihadistes plusieurs
d'entre eux font l'objet d'une
inscription au fichier des personnes
recherchées
le milieu carcéral constitue également
une menace un défi majeur en termes de
radicalisation prosélytisme passage à
l'acte depuis le 26 juillet 2018
1976 individus inscrits au fichier des
signalements pour la prévention de la
radicalisation à caractère terroriste
sont sortis de prison dont 290
terroristes islamistes aujourd'hui 1073
individus ont suivi actif sont
incarcérés 71 d'entre eux vont sortir
prison d'ici la fin de l'année 13 a
condamné pour terrorisme
58 radicaliser sans compter les
libérations inopinés et pouvant
intervenir à tout moment plusieurs
années ont passé depuis la défaite
militaire de dèche irix irak syrie
l'évolution de la situation de ce que
l'on appelle les lionceaux du califat
les sorties de prison des personnes
radicaliser font apparaître une
permanence de la menace terroriste
d'inspiration islamiste sur notre
territoire selon les services de
renseignement à un niveau élevé
aujourd'hui quelles mesures le
gouvernement n'est-il en oeuvre pour
gérer anticipé ces situations concernant
les lionceaux du califat rester sur
place un revenu en france et les sorties
de prison qui font peser sur notre pays
risques terroristes élevés
[Applaudissements]
la parole le cas la ministre
déléguée chargée d'un citoyenneté madame
chapeau
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice je veux commencer avant de
répondre à votre question bien sûr par
une pensée pour l'ensemble des victimes
des attentats terroristes islamistes que
la france a eu à déplorer sur son seul
nous étions nombreux à être notamment
dimanche à dernier ensemble devant l'
hyper cacher pour leur rendre hommage et
je veux bien sûr avoir une pensée pour
eux je veux bien sûr vous dire également
l'engagement de tout le gouvernement
avec le président la république pour
mieux protéger les français face à cette
menace islamiste depuis 2010 est ce sont
plus de trente sept attentats
terroristes qui ont été déjouées par nos
forces de sécurité intérieure je
voudrais saluer l'action permanente des
services de renseignement et rappeler
ici l'engagement du ministère de
l'intérieur puisque avec gérald darmanin
nous avons continué l'augmentation des
moyens humains alloués aux services
spécialisés en matière de lutte
antiterroriste avec un effort sans
précédent puisque au total ce sont mille
900 postes supplémentaires qui auront
été créés d'ici la fin du quinquennat
nous avons également il vous le savez et
mesdames et messieurs les parlementaires
ce que vous y avait fortement contribué
fait évoluer notre législation pour
l'adapter notamment en matière de
renseignement ce qu'ils répondent plus
particulièrement à la question que vous
posez madame la sénatrice veut penser à
la loi par exemple du 31 juillet 2021
relative à la prévention des actes de
terrorisme et aux renseignements que
nous avons débattu ici même ensemble qui
a notamment permis de pérenniser les
dispositions de la loi si sts et la
technique de l'algorithme en les
adaptant à l'évolution de la menace
enfin vous le savez l'action de l'état
se concentre non seulement sur la
question du terrorisme et de la
radicalisation violente mais aussi sur
ce terreau du terrorisme sur la lutte
contre la radicalisation contre le repli
communautaire le gouvernement porte
cette stratégie globale de lutte contre
l'islamisme et je veux dire que la loi
du 24 août 2000 21 qui conforte le
respect des principes de la république
que nous avons porté avec le ministre de
l'intérieur et avec monsieur garde des
sceaux en constituer la clé de voûte et
en ce sens je sais l'engagement du sénat
notamment de mesdames les sénatrice
jacqueline eustache brinio madame la
sénatrice dominique veryant madame la
sénatrice agnès canayer et je veux dire
que notre mot d'ordre est celui que nous
avons pensé porter ensemble pardon c'est
de dire que pas un euro d'argent public
ne doit talent et financé les ennemis de
la république c'est le sens du contrat
d'engagement républicain que nous avons
voté et qui entre en oeuvre depuis le
1er janvier 2022 nous avons signé
d'ailleurs les premiers à poser avec
madame la maire afin de faire en sorte
de toujours dû lutter contre ce terreau
du terrorisme et contre la
radicalisation violente je vous remercie
la parole est un autre collègue hervé
maurey pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues en tant que président du
groupe d'amitié france asie centrale je
souhaite interroger le ministre les
affaires étrangères sur la situation au
kazakhstan la forte hausse des prix du
carburant a donné lieu au début de
l'année à un mouvement de contestation
sociale de grande ampleur qui s'est
transformé en violentes émeutes marquées
par des échanges de tirs le saccage de
bâtiments et les pillages ces événements
ont conduit le président tokayev a
demandé le soutien militaire de
l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective pour contrer ce que les
autorités kazakhes au qualifié d'
attaque terroriste
dans ce cadre deux mille hommes
essentiellement des russes ont été
déployés dans le pays face à cette
situation pouvait vous monsieur le
ministre tout d'abord nous rassurer sur
la sécurité des français qui se trouvent
sur place et nous faire ensuite
connaître votre analyse de la situation
s'agit-il d'une tentative de
déstabilisation du pouvoir comme
l'indiquent les autorités et si oui à
l'initiative de qui ou s'agit-il d'un
mouvement spontané ne faut-il pas se
préoccuper de la présence de militaires
russes dans ce pays qui vient de
célébrer le 30e anniversaire de son
indépendance
quelle est la position et l'action de la
france et de l'union européenne sur ce
sujet par ailleurs la france s'est
fortement investi dans cette région
comme en témoigne la récente visite du
ministre du commerce extérieur dans ce
pays dans quelle mesure ces évènements
post il affecter notre nos intérêts dans
la région
particulièrement la provision de nos
centrales nucléaires en uranium dont le
kazakhstan est le premier producteur
mondial
on vous répondre la parole aux milices
délégué en charge du commerce extérieur
de l'attractivité
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur président mort et nous suivons
évidemment avec la plus grande attention
les événements récents qui se sont
déroulés au kazakhstan ce vous rappelle
à la hausse des prix de l'énergie
a provoqué un mouvement de protestation
d'ampleur sociale dans le pays et cette
crise sociale s'est transformée en crise
politique
cette crise a entraîné un certain nombre
de violences très graves qui sont
intervenus avec un certain nombre de
victimes avec un bilan provisoire
probablement lourd il compris avec un
nombre très important de blessés nous
avons condamné les violences qui se sont
intervenus en en appelant bien
évidemment à la désescalade détention et
au dialogue politique nous avons
également l ministre le drian l'a dit la
semaine dernière dès les premiers
éléments connus rappeler toute
l'attention que nous avions à l'égard du
respect des libertés fondamentales
de la liberté d'expression et la liberté
de la presse et nous souhaitons que
toute la lumière soit faite sur les
circonstances ayant conduit à ces
événements dramatiques nous sommes par
ailleurs attentif au respect durable de
la souveraineté et de l'autonomie
d'action des oreilles des autorités
kazakhes qui ont fait appel vous l'avez
rappelé à l'assistance de l'organisation
du traité de sécurité collective
un contingent grande majorité russe a
donc été déployés pour sécuriser les
sites stratégiques du pays il est
indispensable que les parties
extérieures impliqué temporairement dans
cette situation contribue à la
désescalade détention puis se retire
dans le respect du calendrier indiqué
publiquement par les autorités kazakhes
jean yves le drian s'est entretenu de
cette crise avec josep borrell et nous
maintiendrons tant que présidence du
conseil de l'union européenne
à log étroit avec le service européen
pour l'action extérieure ainsi qu'avec
nos partenaires de l'union européenne le
kazakhstan est un partenaire important
de l'union européenne et de la france
vous avez rappelé mon déplacement en mai
dernier au kazakhstan est aussi un
partenaire important comme nous l'avons
vu récemment avec la crise afghane
j'ajoute que nous avons mis en oeuvre
ces derniers jours lui vigilance toute
particulière concernant la sécurité la
communauté française au kazakhstan est
d'ailleurs une cellule de crise a été
mise en place et a permis d'informer nos
compatriotes et de maintenir un contact
étroit avec nos ressentis sans qui le
souhaitent je vous remercie
monsieur mort et
oui je remercie monsieur mise de vos
réponses même si je n'ai pas eu de
réponses à toutes mes questions je
voudrais juste l'un quelques secondes
qu'il me reste dire qu'après l'épisode
ukrainiens et biélorusses nous ne devons
pas être naïfs et je crois que la france
qui a pris la présidence du conseil de
l'union européenne doit adresser un
message clair à la russie pour garantir
l'indépendance des pays de la région
garantir également la paix et ne pas
être un simple spectateur de ce qui s'y
passe
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
françois bonhomme pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre la violence se banalise notre
pays parmi les victimes de cette
violence se en constante augmentation
notre pays figure les maires et les élus
entre janvier et novembre derniers s'en
sont deux parlementaires et 656 enseigne
maires et adjoints ont été victimes
d'agressions physiques
1186 d'entre eux ont été ciblés chacun
dans cet hémicycle connaît des élus de
son département qui ont été insultés
menacés et plusieurs reçoivent
régulièrement des lettres de menaces
afin de les intimider le président
larcher a souhaité que le sénat se
constitue systématiquement partie civile
et je la remercie ce phénomène est
d'autant plus grave que ces violences
sont tournés vers les dépositaires de
l'autorité publique et notamment des
dépositaires nos mandats électifs la
violence contre les élus vous l'avez dit
a explosé de 47% des militants 30%
d'autres doutent rage en plus à l'heure
du bilan ces chiffres rappellent que le
bilan n'est pas bon il n'y a jamais eu
autant d'élus victimes d'agressions le
gouvernement donne le sentiment face à
cela d'une impuissance caractériser les
protestations les circulaires
ministérielles semble sans grand effet
sans grand effet car les poursuites ne
sont pas forcément systématique et bien
peu d'élus agressés sont informés des
suites réservées à les affaires qu'ils
aux affaires qui les concernant madame
la ministre j'aimerais savoir quelles
mesures concrètes vous comptez prendre
pour faire diminuer ce nombre
d'agressions et faire en sorte enfin que
les statistiques évoluent dans le bon
sens
pour vous répondre à la parole et
rmistes délégué en charge de la
citoyenneté la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur françois bonhomme d'abord
plusieurs que c'est vrai depuis
plusieurs semaines de nombreux élus sont
victimes d'intimidations de menaces de
mort d'agression grave ce phénomène
inacceptable s'aggraver d'ailleurs en
début de semaine le président de la
république lui même je regarde
l'ensemble de l'assemblée mais je peux
vous regardez si vous y tenez monsieur
sénateurs avec plaisir en début de
semaine je disais donc que monsieur
président la république s'est lui même
exprimé en faisant part de son
indignation et de son soutien à
l'ensemble des élus qui ont vécu et ses
agressions comme nous l'avons fait nous
mêmes vous avez eu l'amabilité de le
rappeler le gouvernement a pris un
certain nombre de circulaires et de lois
qui ont été votées je veux dire que la
loi du 27 décembre 2010 9 permet
notamment de renforcer la protection
juridique mais aussi de renforcer
notamment la formation des élus en lien
avec les forces de l'ordre le ministère
de l'intérieur s'est également mobilisée
pour un télégramme aux préfets le 29
décembre chaque fai sera
systématiquement systématiquement
signalé au procureur de la république
par les forces de police et de
gendarmerie cela vient s'ajouter à la
circulaire du garde des sceaux du 7
septembre 2020 sur une réponse pénale
ferme et rapide et en plus de cela je
veux dire que les élus désormais par
ailleurs pourront déposer plainte en
mairie ou dans tout autre lieu de leur
convenance policiers et gendarmes
devront par ailleurs systématiquement
prévoir des permanences
de députés et de sénateurs et leur
domicile au sein de leur patrouille par
ailleurs nous renforçons également la
veille sur les réseaux sociaux pour
mieux signaler les messages haineux je
veux remercier les services de pharos
pour leur mobilisation et dire que les
réseaux sociaux sont hélas devenu un
vecteur majeur de violences d' insulte
envers les élus et je vais vous dire que
nous travaillons en ce moment même avec
les plateformes pour qu'elle puisse
prendre tout leur rôle de modération
plus rapide enfin je veux saluer
l'initiative notamment du président de
l'assemblée nationale à richard ferrand
qui réaffirme avec les présidents de
tous groupes constitués qu'aucun débat
démocratique ne peut se dérouler sous la
menace et je sais que monsieur le
président gérard larcher ici présents et
vous tous partager pleinement cette
volonté d'apaisement du débat public je
vais vous dire que le gouvernement la
partage aussi et sera toujours aux côtés
des élus quels qu'ils soient pour les
soutenir face à cette violence et
menaces je vous remercie
monsieur bonhomme
madame la ministre ces locations
gouvernement j'aimerais bien que vous
répondiez à la question qui vous est
posée on a l'impression que vous lisez
de manière mécanique vous fiche qu'elle
côtoie la question ce qui fort
désagréable je vous parle de des
agressions notre victime les élus et
vous me vous mais grenet un chapelet de
platitudes et de choses qu'on sait déjà
on le sait parfaitement simplement les
agressions se poursuivre mais la
ministre a et les élus locaux n'ont que
faire de vos mots de réconfort à partie
au moment où la situation s'aggrave ce
que je vais vous dire et par conséquent
ça ne sert à rien parce que tout ça
finit par marquer l'impuissance du
gouvernement à juguler ce phénomène mais
la ministre le phantom le sentiment quoi
que vous en disiez le sentiment
d'impunité se répand et malheureusement
le seul critère à la matière de
l'efficace est votre politique publique
c'est le résultat est malheureusement ce
résultat est aujourd'hui inexistants
la parole
et à notre collègue patrice joly
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président
l'effondrement de la biodiversité le
réchauffement climatique deviennent des
sources majeures d'instabilité dans un
contexte de montée des inégalités et
d'effritement de la cohésion sociale
il devient en conséquence impératif
d'accélérer les transitions l'objectif a
été clairement défini il nous faut
baisser d'ici 2030 nos émissions de gaz
à effet de serre de 55% par rapport à
1990 cela ne se fera pas par magie il
est demandé des efforts
d'investissements massifs aux
entreprises comme aux ménages en vue de
décors bonne et notre société est de
réduire notre dépendance aux énergies
fossiles
au moment où l'inflation pèse lourdement
sur le pouvoir d'achat des ménages et
asphyxient nombre de nos entreprises
monsieur le ministre le remboursement
des emprunts réalisés pour financer les
plans de relance et les dizaines ou
plutôt les centaines de milliards
d'investissements indispensables pour
relever les défis climatiques et
numérique en mettant en oeuvre des
transition socialement juste et
soutenable appelle des moyens importants
qui ne sont pas couverts par les
nouvelles ressources propres prévues à
l'échelle européenne en effet ces trois
nouvelles ressources devrait générer en
moyenne que 10 7 milliards d'euros par
an d'ici 2030 on est loin du compte ceci
conduit à revenir sur les règles
budgétaires européennes je pense ici aux
référentiels il ya la dette les fameux
3% et 60% du pib issu du pacte de
stabilité et de croissance qui ont fait
leur temps montré leurs limites et sont
incompatibles avec les cette urgence à
investir massivement le président de la
république a semblé un temps s'inscrire
dans cette perspective monsieur le
ministre qu'on est il aujourd'hui alors
que lors de la présentation des
priorités de la présidence française de
l'union européenne son propos à ce sujet
est apparu très évasif
pour vous répondre à la parole et oblige
délégué en charge des groupes publics
messieurs 10 heures merci monsieur le
président monsieur le sénateur jolie
vous m'interrogez sur le cadre
budgétaire européen à la fois sur les
règles qui régissent son fonctionnement
mais aussi sur eux les nouvelles
ressources dans l'union a décidé de se
doter cela me permet de répondre en
trois points le premier pour dire que le
simple fait que l'union européenne est
décidée il est maintenant un peu plus
d'un an de se doter de nouvelles
ressources propres à la fois pour
financer le remboursement des emprunts
contractés solidairement et mettre en
oeuvre le plan de relance européen et un
progrès majeur et à soutenir matière
d'intégration et de solidarité
européenne dans la mise en oeuvre du
plan de relance si vous savez dans
l'existant du président de la république
il n'y aurait pas eu définition
nouvelles ressources propres et nous
n'aurions pas même ce débat aujourd'hui
avec un intérêt particulier porté par la
france à la définition ses ressources
propres pendant l'année 2022 priorité
dans étant donnée aux mécanismes
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières au
système d'échangé de quotas nous savons
aussi qu'il faut croiser son vin et
expressions le débat sur la fiscalité
internationale et les minimum de
taxation avec l'accord intervenu au sein
le tpe je crois vous partagerez avec moi
le fait que cet accord sa noce et des
oeufs sur une fiscalité minimum et la
démonstration des combats les plus longs
peuvent être gagnés personne n'aurait
imaginé il ya quelques mois ou quelques
années que nous puissions collectivement
aboutir sur un tel accord en matière de
fiscalité minimum des multinationales il
y a au delà des ressources propres et
vous avez compris notre attachement
celui du président de la république bien
évidemment la volonté de réfléchir à
nouveau cadre budgétaire la commission
européenne a communiqué le 19 octobre
dernier et elle a posé quelques
principes au débat qui va se dérouler
tout au long du premier semestre le
premier centre ou principe est celui de
la crédibilité il faut avoir des règles
qui encadrent l'évolution des finances
publiques en europe garantissant la
crédibilité de notre économie comme
d'autres prenaient le deuxième principe
la souplesse et d'intelligence la
souplesse pour pouvoir répondre aux
crises et l'intelligence pour financer
les transitions nécessaires c'est le cas
la transition écologique c'est le cas de
la transition numérique cela s'inscrit
aussi dans la droite ligne des plans
d'investissement qui sont mises en
oeuvre au niveau communautaire comme au
niveau européen ce débat est ouvert il
ne faut pas le précipiter si nous
voulons qu'ils puissent être réussie et
pendant tout le premier semestre la
france dans son rôle à la présidence
française de l'union européenne va
permettre à veiller à ce que ce débat
puisse aboutir la manière la plus
consensuelle mais toujours avec cet
objectif en tête l'intelligence d'une
règle pour financer les investissements
conclut la souplesse et la crédibilité
joli
[Applaudissements]
merci les transactions les transitions
pardon décide de changer de braquet il
devient donc urgent de sortir d'une
vision conservatrice des politiques
budgétaires que montrer leur
inadéquation règlement des crises qu'il
s'agisse par exemple de la résolution de
la crise de 29 ou celle plus récente de
2008 2012 c'est en s'écartant de ces
règles que la rue construction
européenne ne peut être mené à bon
rythme lors d'après la seconde guerre
mondiale
c'est une perspective d'investissement
d'une ampleur analogue qui nous attend
jour merci
monsieur blocher
et messieurs mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'économie dont nous
regrettons que sa présence au sénat ne
fasse pas partie de ces bonnes
résolutions 2022
clovis de l'éclairer a quand même trouvé
le temps de déclarer dans la presse en
début de semaine nous ne pouvons pas
garder une balance commerciale
déficitaire
car c'est le reflet de la faiblesse de
notre économie intérieure fin de
citation
monsieur bruno le maire avait fait au
début de son arrivée au ministère
l'économie a maintenant près de cinq ans
le redressement de la balance
commerciale une priorité
or patatras le déficit extérieur de la
france sera historique en 2021 alors
même que la croissance et vous le
claironner suffisamment n'aura jamais
été aussi forte alors ma question est
simple au gouvernement comment expliquer
votre échec
pour vous répondre la parole
il faut ministre
chargé
l'activité pardon mesdames et messieurs
les sénatrices et sénateurs
cette question est une question majeure
la question du commerce extérieur
regardons la situation
les exportations après la crise
sanitaire seront repartis d'une façon
très dynamique grâce à l'engagement et
la résilience des chefs d'entreprise qui
ont l'esprit de conquête tournée vers
l'international et qui ont malgré les
difficultés du fret maritime malgré des
difficultés la crise qu'ovide ont repris
le chemin de l'exportation il n'y a
jamais eu en france autant depuis 20 ans
d'entreprises exportatrices plus de cent
trente six mille entreprises
exportatrices
bande bien nombre de secteurs les
exportations sont largement en hausse
par rapport à la période précédente
avant la crise mais il ya une croissance
économique forte en france comme vous le
savez à plus de 6,5 points en 2021 qui
crée de la consommation qui est en
partie vient de l'extérieur de notre
pays qui crée des besoins pour notre
industrie en matière de composants et
qui donc mécaniquement augmente fait
augmenter nos importations sans compter
comme ça l'a été a appelé tout à l'heure
un des sénateurs l'augmentation du coût
de la facture énergétique du fait de la
hausse très sensible des matières
énergétiques de du pétrole en
particulier est donc la différence entre
la hausse des exportations dans un
certain nombre de secteurs importants et
l'augmentation plus importante des
importations fait creuser le déficit
commercial des biens
[Applaudissements]
c'est un élément conjoncturel
d'un point de vue structurel le
gouvernement est à la tâche pour réduire
ce déficit 1la mais l'amélioration de la
compétitivité du pays de la
réindustrialisation du pays du pays 3
une politique commerciale moins naïve
plus offensive et c'est ton coeur de la
présidence française de l'union
européenne et 3 et 4ème point
accompagner les entreprises à
l'international et comme je vous le
disais nous n'avons jamais eu autant
d'entreprises exportatrices
depuis 20 ans que cette année en france
monsieur boscher
merci monsieur le ministre pour un ses
réponses qui sont effectivement les
vôtres ce qui est certain et vous avez
évoqué le prix de l'énergie la france
pour la première fois va apporter
l'électricité alors nous étions
exportateur net pour la première fois et
pour la première fois comme vous l'avez
dit monsieur le ministre nous allons
même apporté du charbon pour mettre dans
nos centrales à charbon pour compenser
et nous allons donc comme cela encore
une fois augmenter notre déficit
commercial mais non seulement nous
sommes les premiers du déficit
commercial européen mais nous sommes
aussi mes chers collègues les premiers
du déficit public européen et voilà
comment on dépense l'argent des français
n'ont pas à faire leurs biens mais à
faiblir comme l'a dit votre ministre de
tutelle l'économie intérieure du pays
car même sur les biens manufacturés
monsieur le ministre les prix des biens
importés augmente de 19 % des biens
comme ce que nous exportons de 14% ça
veut dire que la facture pour le
français c'est plus cher alors qu'on est
le roi des déficits jumeaux on ne peut
pas donner de leçons alors quand on
prend la présidence de l'union
européenne pour entraîner tout le monde
il ne faut pas être le dernier de la
classe
la parole l'état
notre collègue yves bouloux pour le
groupe l'est républicain vous avez la
parole
[Applaudissements]
merci président monsieur le président
monsieur nuit sur les chers collègues du
film pardon pardon
un nouveau protocole sanitaire à l'école
a été annoncée le troisième en moins
d'une semaine il ya un an personne était
vaccinée les enfants n'étaient pas testé
aujourd'hui tout le monde est vacciner
les enfants sont testés des classes ont
été fermées pour un cas positif puis
trois cas et on est fermé plus en isoler
les familles c'est fini mais je te tests
n'étaient pas fiables ils le sont
devenus avant le masque éviter d'être
cas quand est
désormais à cas positifs dans une place
cédée mater on teste toutes les classes
on ne comprend plus rien
le nouveau protocole va supprimer l
attente au laboratoire mais des familles
devront néanmoins réalisé trois tests
naso pharyngé tous les deux jours à
l'enfant ceci dès 3 ans pour une famille
de trois enfants sur une semaine seul
elle représente 9 des tests est ce
réaliste
quant à la vaccination des mois de 12
ans qui d'ailleurs ne va pas de soi
le protocole est le même quel que soit
le statut vaccinal
vous avez souhaité laisser les écoles
ouvertes sur le ministre pour le
bien-être des enfants et c'est très bien
mais depuis la rentrée des enfants
vivent dans l'angoissé la douleur des
tests une petite torture et
l'incertitude d'être accueillis à
l'école vous avez annoncé un nouveau
protocole il n'est toujours pas publié
monsieur ministre quand cesserons-nous
de naviguer à vue
avec des protocoles inadaptée
min
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs sur le sénateur
vous venez d'écrire des inconvénients
liés à l'existence du virus nous
aimerions tous que ces inconvénients
n'existe pas et je pense qu'il est assez
facile de les décrire il est évidemment
plus difficile de les gérer et de
piloter à vue je reprends votre
expression oui en effet le virus oblige
la france comme d'autres pays évidemment
à piloter à vue c'est à dire à regarder
ce qui se passe concrètement et à avoir
une réponse adaptée donc les
descriptions des évolutions que vous
avez fait n est jamais qu est la
description de la légimité qu'il a fallu
à voir quand j l'agilité c'est celle de
tout le corps social et s'agissant de
l'éducation nationale évidemment de tous
les personnels de l'éducation nationale
et des collectivités locales auquel je
rends à nouveau hommage et cette agilité
c'est ce qui nous a permis d'être le
pays avec l'école ouverte l'année
dernière et de l'être encore et bien sûr
c'est difficile bien sûr il ya des
souffrances au quotidien bien sûr les
tests naso pharyngé pour les enfants ça
ne nous plaît pas ça ne valait pas plus
à moi qu'à vous j'aimerais bien que ça
n'existe pas mais nous nous référons aux
autorités de santé nous regardons ce qui
se passe dans le monde et croyez moi
nous n'avons pas à rougir du bilan ce
qui me frappe c'est cette volonté
toujours de relativiser ce bilan alors
que internationalement il est reconnu
que la france est le pays qui a réussi
justement cette politique de l'école
ouverte grâce à nous tous collectivement
face au pays entier pourquoi ne sommes
nous pas capables tous bancs confondus
de développer cette fierté nationale
autour de cet objectif est de continuer
dans cette phase qui je l'espère et la
dernière nous verrons bien quelle est
l'évolution du virus mais il ya aussi
des scénarios optimistes et ce scénario
optimiste est évidemment celui que nous
appelons de nos voeux alors oui le
protocole sanitaire a évolué peut-être
évoluera-t-il encore peut-être cela
suscitera de nouveau des critiques en
tout cas nous le ferons avec pragmatisme
avec le désir de bien faire peut-être
parfois avec des choses qui ne sont pas
parfaites c'est évident
lyon pas que nous sommes en situation de
crise ne faisons pas des critiques
ordinaire dans un moment extraordinaire
je vous remercie monsieur boulou
[Applaudissements]
si
mathieu ministre je vous demande
instamment de cesser cette politique de
gribouille pour les enfants de france si
monsieur le premier ministre la
démission luminis merci nos prochaines
questions d'actualité auront lieu
mercredi 19 janvier à 15h fait suspendre
la séance et sera reprise à 16h35 pour
la suite de l'examen du projet de loi
renforçant les outils de gestion de
crise sanitaire et modifiant le code de
la santé publique la séance est
suspendue
[Musique]
vous venez de suivre en direct et en
intégralité la séance de questions au
gouvernement et tout de suite on va
rejoindre steve jourdain dans
l'hémicycle du sénat